en france il y aurait 4 millions de
consommateurs du cannabis 1 millions
fument régulièrement et 500000
quotidiennement un marché en pleine
expansion
250 tonnes de cannabis seraient
consommées chaque année pourtant la loi
est plutôt répressive dans notre pays
tout fumeur risque un an de prison et
une amende de 3750 ont une politique du
tout répressif qui ne semble pas
effrayer les consommateurs la
prohibition favoriserait la consommation
est pire
l'émergence d'organisations mafieuses
certains voudraient donc légaliser et
dépénalisé l'usagé du cannabis
une fausse bonne idée pour william
lowenstein addictologue réputé lui
parlerai plutôt de décriminalisation car
légaliser ce seraient incités à la
consommation
quelqu'un est pris en possession d'une
drogue et quelle qu'elle soit il en est
dépendant il ne doit pas être puni pour
cela
pourquoi punir il doit par contre
rentrer dans un système qui l'aide et ce
système il doit pas dépendre du
ministère de l'intérieur mais du
ministère de la santé en pratique et ce
qui se passe c'est faire comprendre aux
gens que ce n'est pas une faute pénale
que c'est pas un crime d'être malade ou
de consommer mais par contre qu'un pays
n'incite pas à la consommation
essentiellement parce que la guerre à la
drogue a échoué ce qui est une réalité
la réalité judiciaire ses 158
l'interpellation et 6000 personnes
incarcérées pour usage de drogue chaque
année en france et le combat doit
continuer c'est ce que pense jean claude
delage patron du syndicat de police
alliance les sanctions judiciaires
doivent être plus lourde et il faut
donner encore plus de moyens aux
policiers de dire aujourd'hui que parce
qu'on n'arriverait pas éventuellement à
lutter il faudrait légaliser
dépénaliser je trouve c'est une solution
raccourci assez facile et qu'il n'est
absolument pas responsables aujourd'hui
on entend parler de la dépénalisation et
la légalisation en matière de cannabis
de haschich mais alors pourquoi demain
aussi ne pas entendre parler de la
légalisation sur le trafic de la cocaïne
de l'héroïne de drogues dures parce que
ça certainement ça sera la porte ouverte
à ce type de débat hypocrisie générale
pour laurent appel arrêtons le tout
répressif la prohibition a montré ses
limites
cet homme se bat depuis trente ans pour
légaliser le cannabis il faut désormais
encadrer la consommation
à terme on contrôlera la qualité du
produit et les dealers et l'économie
souterraine disparaîtront
progressivement la prohibition absolue
est un laxisme au total c'est un échec
la prohibition est laxiste parce que on
n'arrive pas à l'appliquer complètement
mes parents la laissant dériver on
obtient des effets pervers et des effets
pire que la substance en elle même si on
prend l'exemple de l'alcool ou du tabac
par contre une régulation publique avec
prohibition partiel comme on a sur
l'alcool le tabac a entraîné une baisse
de la consommation d'alcool en quatre
ans en temps et une baisse de la
consommation du tabac
donc oui à la consommation du haschich
une consommation encadrée une
consommation encadrer et réguler on
demande absolument pas un far west où
tout le monde consomme tout et n'importe
quoi on est pour la consommation privée
dans des lieux privés entre adultes on
va pas plus loin
légaliser dépénaliser décriminaliser le
débat revient fréquemment mais la classe
politique française
hormis les verts et dont son ensemble
plutôt contre tout changement
politiquement tabou le sujet devrait le
rester
un an des élections présidentielle et
dans un contexte plutôt sécuritaire on
voit mal quel leader politique oserait
se prononcer pour la légalisation du
cannabis
stéphane gatignon bruno beschizza
bonsoir nous voulons voir un reportage
de christophe kulikauskis avant peau
d'une polémique suscitée par vous
stéphane gatignon vous plus exactement
une idée que vous défendez dans ce livre
stéphane gatignon avec serge supersac un
ancien policier pour en finir avec les
dealers chez grasset cette idée c'est la
légalisation du cannabis alors c'est une
proposition et la polémique qui s'en est
suivie qui nous a conduits à nous poser
la question faut-il légaliser le
cannabis pour en finir avec les dealers
alors vous êtes maire europe ecologie
les verts depuis 2001 de sevran vous
êtes confrontés au quotidien avec les
problèmes de trafic
vous êtes également au conseil général
d'île de france alors je vous pose la
question vous y répondre et simplement
et je connais un peu votre réponse
faut-il légaliser le cannabis pour en
finir avec les trafics
parce que c'est ça notre proposition
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on est
arrivé à un moment où on a tout un tas
de secteurs de villes en france qui sont
complètement pris par le trafic de
stupéfiants qui essentiellement chez
nous du trafic de cannabis et
aujourd'hui on est à la halle aurait en
fait d'un monde où finalement ces
trafiquants sont en train de structurer
une vraie mafia qui va déstabiliser tout
un tas de secteurs et deuxièmement il ya
un énorme problème de santé publique
parce qu'aujourd'hui fumer n'est pas
anodin et on a
c'est vrai problème on y reviendra bruno
lui si ça vous êtes ancien commandant de
police
ancien secrétaire général du syndicat
police synergie officiers et vous est
donc au conseil général jean dreuil
arriver est arrivé
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes en charge
des questions de sécurité de l'ump
et quand je vous pose la question
faut-il légaliser le cannabis pour en
finir avec leader vous répondez quoi ni
l'égalisation ni dépénalisation rentrera
pas celle des draps y ait une différence
qui est de taille mais je reconnais
comme une chose à stéphane gatignon ces
kilos - lui la franchise en tant
qu'homme de gauche de dire clairement et
publiquement ce que beaucoup d'hommes de
gauche pensent mais n'ose pas dire sur
un sujet très délicat pourquoi parce
qu'il concerne nos enfants alors oubliez
d'ailleurs distingué l'égalisation et
dépénalisation oui sinon c'est quoi
c est ce qu on dit que le cannabis est
un produit comme un autre déjà à la base
de tout or tout cela dit ça ne réaliser
sa part un médecin pas un pharmacien
aujourd'hui en france nous dit le
cannabis est un produit neutre
cette inquiétude non simplement
aujourd'hui on a deux types de drogues
les drogues licites les drogues
illicites
aujourd'hui en drogues licites ya
l'alcool et le tabac aujourd'hui
l'alcool fait un million huit morts sur
la planète par an le tabac 5 millions
les drogues donc pas le cannabis mais
les drogues dures font trois cent mille
morts à en rajouter au nom le fléau il
existe déjà pour moi le cannabis on est
l'un fléau dans le cannabis aujourd'hui
est un fléau cas des conséquences à la
fois sur la santé parce que où monsieur
beschizza raison voyez vous êtes
d'accord sur la sueur des chaussures
menaçantes remis en plus de ça la
question de la qualité de ce qui est
fumée aujourd'hui notamment le taux de
thc dont cannabis
c'est là la molécule anodine si vous
voulez donc dont cannabis il est devenu
à nagano est devenue très forte dans le
cannabis aujourd'hui qui est saisi il ya
des produits a dû la mère de chameau du
goudron les graphes
il ya des choses qui sont pas là il ya
un vrai problème de santé publique
aujourd'hui près de 20 % plus de 20% des
accidents du travail sont liées au
cannabis
aujourd'hui on sait très bien qu'il y en
a quand on fait quand même près de
600000 personnes fument tous les jours
c'est des jeunes et des moins jeunes
parce que excusez moi j'ai j'ai
maintenant la petite quarantaine mais il
ya beaucoup de gens encore autour de moi
qui fume depuis 20 ans qui sont
aujourd'hui cadres qui sont aujourd'hui
ingénieurs avocats chefs d'entreprise ça
touche non quand on dit c'est un truc de
jeunes c'est pas vrai ça touche
aujourd'hui toutes les catégories de
population toutes les classes sociales
et c'est vrai que c'est un vrai fléau
donc aujourd'hui je pense que pour
dépénaliser légaliser ça permet à la
fois de suivre la qualité du produit est
bon viendra plus tard de vue et surtout
d'engager des vraies campagnes de
prévention comme on fait sur l'alcool
vous savez que je parle pas moral mais
on peut pas parler santé publique la loi
me faire avoir là depuis tout à l'heure
par la santé publique et j'aimerais
qu'on parle économique parce que les
dealers demain vous légaliser le produit
qui contient 6 % du fameux th et comme
ce sont des bons commerciaux ils
mettront sur le marché de nouveaux
produits qui contiennent 18% de
substance et qui vont se refaire une
clientèle donc c'est l'échelle de
perroquet alors vous pensez que seule la
répression peut rêver c'est la
répression dont certains dans la journée
six au jeu sur les consommateurs
le but c'est demain puissent comparer
les produits j'aimerais comprendre du
vecteur c'est que vous savez vous à
sevran que ce sont les mêmes qui
tiennent dans leurs mains ce trafic de
cannabis 9,6 le trafic d'héroïne mais
aussi la cocaïne et vous m'aiderez césar
hafid d'armé vous n'appelez pas la
légalisation du trafic d'armes parce que
ça dérange en date en défaut et sido
plusieurs études montrent que fait la
police quand vous faites cette
énumération mais la trame de la police
faisant déguster la police fait son
travail mais on est aujourd'hui face à
des bandes au moins de novembre 19 gros
dealer de votre ville ont été
interpellés le lendemain ils ont été
remis dehors le 23 février 10 gros
dealer de votre mobile ont été
interpellés ils ont été placés gatignon
qui est responsable de ces fallu y
penser je me retourne vers vous puisque
vous aviez posé la question la police a
fait son travail
pourquoi sont remis dehors je réponds
répondre à la remarque ça c'est la vraie
c'est le travail de la justice moi je
suis pas juge et séparation entre la
jurée commander la légalisation attendez
on parle pas de la même chose là c'est
bon à temps moi ce que je dis
aujourd'hui on a dit 1le aujourd'hui la
le cannabis dans le tableau des drogues
le cannabis pour tous les scientifiques
à peu près dans ses seins c'est
dangereux 2 c'est à peu près
l'équivalent de l'accord ça veut dire
qu'il faut aujourd'hui comme on traite
l'alcool il faut traiter de la même
façon qu analyste
commercialisée comme on commercialise le
beige le réseau otayo
et laissez-moi finir simplement il ya la
question de la production
trois sources de production aujourd'hui
il y avait les productions à l'étranger
notamment dans certains pays d'afrique
du nord je pense qu'il faut avoir les
vraies relations avec eux il ya la
cannabiculture aujourd'hui en france on
a de plus en plus de gens qui cultivent
chesaux l'an dernier on arrêtait plaide
2000 cannabiculteurs en france et il ya
la question des agriculteurs qui sont
souvent aussi parfois en tout cas
cannabiculteurs on a souvent dit dans le
sud de la france dans les pieds de maïs
ont trouvé de l'herbe qui est vrai on
n'en trouve pas que dans le sud de la
france voulait aller dans l'oise et
traductions moi je sais exactement il
faut légaliser pour contrôler ce qui se
fait pour ensuite contrôler les circuits
économiques
moi je pense que demain on doit comme
aujourd'hui à des marchands de tabac
marchands de tabac on peut avoir des
gens de gens y mène dans les cigarettes
avoir le cannabis pour rompre avec les
trafiquants au niveau local qu'à c'est
un crime organisé au niveau local mais
aussi cassé est ce que ça fait
il faudra des expériences on a
d'ailleurs non mais sont pas des
réalisations maintenant le problème
faire marcher le biais relève de la rue
laurier choqué ce qu'il ya là au
lendemain de la générosité entre milieux
les jambières et blême aujourd'hui de la
hollande c'est d'abord qu'on a vous
allez amsterdam aujourd'hui vous avez un
bloqueur d'amsterdam pour on est blindé
et blindés notamment de jeunes français
qui viennent fumer dans les gros fish
problème c'est aujourd'hui le jour de l
élan de vous dire j'ai habité entre
l'homme et les lieux mêmes et leurs
commerces et c'est ce qu'on vit un jour
mais pas imminents mais juste qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans ses
expériences à qui n'est pas
reproductible alors au jour
d'aujourd'hui il est constaté que la
théorie des coffee shops ou là-bas
finalement c'est la consommation qui est
libre
les maires de ces grandes villes disent
attention on est en train de fermer des
coffee shops parce qu'on s'aperçoit
qu'avec la meilleure volonté du monde il
n'y a de fait porosité entre ce commerce
qui est légal mais le milieu qui s'est
emparé et j'en reviens ce qui se passe
dans nos cités aujourd'hui il n'ya pas
le dealer de cannabis à côté de celui
qui importe de l'héroïne et de la
cocaïne
ce sont les mêmes réseaux donc même et
je crois votre bonne volonté
demain vous dit on va dissocier il ne
vous laisserons pas faire d'une part
comme je le disais échanges de produits
pour faire naître de nouvelles
addictions vis-à-vis des consommateurs
et d'autre part c'est le même lieu qui
n'acceptera jamais de laisser une part
de marché
faut être à l'aise 12 pourrons à ce que
je reviens la priorité c'est la
répression contre ses grands trafiquants
c'est là dessus dans ce que je pense
effectivement hollande un ya le problème
du tourisme de la drogue
2 il ya un vrai problème est là dessus
je suis d'accord c'est à dire qu'ils ont
en eux légalisant part on est resté
ancré aujourd'hui dans
notamment aux pays bas sur le
narcotrafic international et c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu tout un tas de production
qui fait qu'il ya pas eu de rupture
semble ne pas aller jusqu'au bout a
contrario on a un pays comme le portugal
qui a dépénalisé depuis dix ans
aujourd'hui c'est nous la cocaïne danger
aujourd'hui qui est montrée en exemple
par l'onu notamment pour le cannabis qui
est montrée en exemple par les mines
obert cocaïne attendez laissez moi
parler moi aujourd'hui je vous parle du
cannabis attendez c'est pas la même
chose et simplement non aujourd'hui wade
se écoutez vous on a on a vu la
proposition en face de vous la vôtre qui
est plus de répression ça conduirait à
incarcérer combien de personnes par an
est ce que notre système carcéral le
permet je milite au sein de l'ump vous
le savez pour la création de 20 minutes
places de prison supplémentaires et je
laisse une complètement non pas pour le
consommateur de stupéfiants
mais pour ces grands trafiquants je n'ai
aucun état d'âme de dire
qu'effectivement francine mans 28 ans de
prison pour les 19 individus et ça
règlerait dans la rivière han solo au
moins déjà on aura un signal fort
blizzard s'est rappelé leur dirais vous
risquez quelque chose aujourd'hui ne
risque rien au niveau de la justice
le modèle de la légalisation de ne
fonctionne pas vous avez des baisers
grande selon vous est ce qu'il ya un
modèle comme celui que vous prônez qui
fonctionne c'est à dire est ce que un
surcroît d'incarcération fonctionne
quelque part dans un pays du monde on
est dans un domaine pour ça que c'est la
solution idéale ne pourra jamais exister
je répète qu'il fait y at-il vraiment
fonctionné mais c'est la moins pire des
solutions
voilà je vous dis chaque c'est la
meilleure pascal chaumont ya un gamin
qui touche un joint c'est un constat
d'échec contre la zone à lui dressé la
consommation de cannabis un des endroits
où un nouvel habit ce nom en france nous
sommes pas comparer au portugal que vous
parlez ou en angleterre par exemple pour
la cocaïne ou live il ya eu une
explosion
on a libéralisé
le cannabis entre eni mais il ya une
explosion de la consommation de cocaïne
attendait sur les côté festif et ne faut
pas comparer les types de consommation
simple bruit je vais j'y vais avant de
temps des monsieur beschizza est inquiet
il a raison parce qu'aujourd'hui on sait
que 42% des jeunes de 17 ans ont touché
en juin
donc ça veut dire que 42% un sur deux
quand on a des enfants à partir de 2 11
y en a un sur deux qui va les toucher et
c'est normal mais après ça fait partie
de la culture comme on apprend à boire
etc
voir mes enfants je leur apprends gré à
ces niveaux là je ne suis pas d'accord
messieurs vous savez qu'on entre dans
une période politique est ce que vous
considérez que ce sujet doit faire
partie des programmes des différents
partis politiques qui vont se présenter
aux suffrages des électeurs bien sûr je
pense qu'effectivement il faut que les
électeurs les pères et les mères de
familles sachent ce que leurs futurs
gouvernants en disent qu'ils n'en
veulent pas mais des gens qui souhaitent
ce type de position sur moi je vous dis
je tiens mon rôle de secrétaire national
ump dans le domaine de la sécurité il y
aura peut-être des prises de positions
différentes
j'assume la mienne vous savez moi je
pensais 1 c'est pas une question franco
française
quand je vois les ans l'ancien par
vicente fox ancien président du mexique
les présidents sud-américains qui ont
dit il faut absolument avoir au niveau
international ce débat la question des
drogues et de la légalisation parce
qu'on peut plus continuer comme ça c'est
des présidents extrêmement réaction
conservateur réactionnaire d'une droite
plutôt dur donc voyez petit à petit ce
débat va toucher tous les bords
politiques
voilà c'est ce que je veux dire ce livre
et vous l'avez souligné a le mérite de
poser la question de lever peut-être un
tabou dans le débat français c'est pas
le moindre de ses mérites stéphane
gatignon serge supersac pour en finir
avec les dealers c'est chez grasset
messieurs merci
[Musique]